all right it is time to check in on
what's trending with our favorite las
vegas now host mercedes martinez there
she is live from the mix 941 studios
mercedes good morning to yous
good morning you too let's get to it
this is what's trending first up the foo
fighters they have cancelled all
upcoming tour dates after the death of
drummer taylor hawkins now the band had
more than 50 shows scheduled around the
world for the rest of the year taylor
hawkins was found dead in his bogota
columbia hotel room while on tour in
south america
and the owners heard the complaints of
the masses and now new overtime rules
are coming for the nfl the nfl
announcing the league owners approved a
change to overtime rules that ensure
both teams will get a possession in
overtime now the rule change will only
apply to the postseason where the
advantage has statistically
been skewed towards the team
winning the overtime coin toss now if
the score remains tied in the postseason
after each team has had a possession
the game
it's going to be decided in traditional
sudden death john heather
football drama um but first mercedes you
know the foo fighters they're supposed
to be performing at the grammys
we haven't heard one way or another i
mean i know they cancelled the shows but
you haven't heard whether they're going
to be at the grammys
actually they have said that they will
no longer be performing at the grammys
so they have pulled out so that is not
happening anymore well yeah okay we'll
get a band together we'll just fill the
spot
mercedes uh not everyone is going to be
going nuts about burger king's newest
items nuts mercedes nuts
i love what you did there okay so burger
king in south korea is rolling out some
new menu items featuring
peanut butter okay so their new peanut
butter stacker consists of two beef
patties topped with mayo pickles
american cheese and a peanut butter
sauce and they're also gonna have a
chicken patty version but here's the one
that actually looks kind of good to me
they're going to be serving up peanut
butter french fries which are french
fries drizzled with peanut butter sauce
right now there are no plants to bring
these new items to the states but i'm
kind of crossing my fingers and hoping
you two will go in on me maybe we can
start a a petition to bring them here
all right real quick
anyone so here's the deal
burger king aside there's a place down
on silverado ranch in silverado ranch i
think it's called slater's
50 50. and they make burgers with peanut
butter and like eggs on them and stuff
and they are mind-blowing they're so
good
yes it's very good it's sneaky good can
we do that with the french fries though
too that's where that's where i need to
go you do it the french fries just make
sure a cardiologist is nearby
that is key
i need my lipitor where's my
oh boy okay you guys can eat that i'm
gonna i'm gonna abstain from that we'll
tell you what it's all about
thanks